this is what we're here for
the brand new dual sense controller so
on first impressions
just looking at the controller it is not
as bright white as i thought it was
going to be from all the marketing and
everything we've seen at the playstation
5 so far
i genuinely thought this was going to be
a bright white it actually has more of a
grayish
tinge to it when you're looking at it uh
in real life so
first impressions it feels really nice
in the hand it feels very familiar if
you've been playing
on a dualshock 4 a lot it just feels a
bit sturdier a little bit heavier
let's start with the charging port we've
already seen the charging cable usb
c it's right at the back there in terms
of the face buttons
they have lost all their color probably
to fit in with this new sleek black and
white
look so shoulder buttons there's a
little more sound feedback when you're
pressing them which actually feels quite
nice they feel like way more responsive
i don't know if it's just because my
dual shock 4 is quite old and it feels a
little bit sticky the face buttons are
actually
a lot softer to press and actually the
touchpad has more of a feedback in it as
well the
dualshock 4 touchpad felt very very soft
to me but this one feels like it's
way more of a button but the face
buttons themselves do feel a lot softer
to press
the thumbsticks have rubber textures on
them
they feel pretty good they actually feel
a little bit firmer the playstation home
button has been replaced it used to be a
circular button
now it's just the playstation logo but
obviously it's actually quite it's
hidden quite well in there so
you're probably not going to hit that
accidentally beneath that
is another button so you can use the
dual sense controller as a microphone
seeing videos and pictures of people in
party chat and using
the dual sense to either do
text-to-speech when they're talking to
their friends and messaging them
or you can use it as a microphone so
this is a button to turn your microphone
on and off if you don't want to use that
feature
beneath it you have a headphone jack
where you can plug in just your regular
headset
if you have an old headset that you're
plugging in you want to use it as a
microphone or just for the headphones
you can plug
it in there it also has kind of a
texturized
plastic on the back so you don't feel
like you're going to drop it it's not
smooth
like the dual shark it feels nice it
feels weighty the options button is now
gone it no longer says options
instead you have this button here which
serves as a replacement
word options is gone you just got the
three lines and on the other side the
share button is gone
this time around it's the create button
uh it has
three lines going in different direction
but this is the button you would hit to
take screenshots
video clips and then mark them up and
share them with your friends